hi everyone I'm here today to talk to
you about networking and go but before I
jump into that a little bit about myself
my name is Sneha and Guba I'm a software
engineer at digitalocean and that is a
photo of my cat which I had to include
for tech cat tax so moving on if you
have has anyone here heard of
digitalocean
oh that's awesome yes you're doing
something right we are a cloud hosting
company located all around the world we
have about 12 data centers at this point
more than a million droplets or what we
like to call virtual machines and we
have a host of other products most
recently kubernetes is a service which
is super exciting database as a service
different types of storage object or
block VPC and a bunch of other
networking products so my talk today is
actually a little bit about my journey
as a software engineer at digitalocean
so let's go back to 2016 this is a year
I joined digital ocean and when I joined
I had no experience with go my
background was with writing casino
gaming companies sorry casino games for
gaming companies in C++ or doing full
stack development but go was something
that was completely new I quickly soon
learned that go has this adorable mascot
this gopher but maybe more importantly
go was designed as a systems language by
a bunch of Googlers meant to increase
developer productivity if we really want
to get into definitions it is a
statically typed memory save compiled
programming language a lot of people let
go because it has excellent concurrency
support and we're just going to go
through a few of what that actually
means so there's these things called go
routines and if you are familiar with go
you've heard of it you've probably heard
of go routines they are lightweight
processes that are multiplexed onto
threads it's very easy to start a go
routine essentially you type go in front
of a function there's also the package
called sync which is part of the
standard library it has a lot of very
useful concurrency primitives it has
mutex is something called sync maps
which are thread safe
it has a variety of different types of
actor go routine groups whether it's
arrow groups or weight groups and we're
actually gonna get into these with some
examples and a little bit so don't worry
about them and then finally there's
channels which are both loved and
frequently hated it's they're
essentially conduit through which you
can send or receive data often between
different go routines with typed
operators so despite having all of these
concurrency features I would say that go
is pretty syntactically simple when I
join digital ocean I found that I could
crock a lot of our code in our mono repo
that was written and go furthermore I
found that even for a lot of open source
go software it's fairly easy to read and
then I like to think are actually my
colleague pointed this out that go
compared to a lot of other languages
does enforce a coding style and a lot of
people don't like it but some also like
this because especially as a newer
engineer onboarding onto a code base
this can be a good thing
so that was 2016 but by 2017 I was
working on internal developing developer
tooling at digitalocean so this meant I
worked with kubernetes specifically how
we could use kubernetes internally I
also and if you're not familiar with
kubernetes it is a container
orchestration and scheduling solution I
also worked a lot with Prometheus which
is a pull based monitoring solution
that's become very popular as well so
through these experiences I also kind of
saw the age of digital ocean kind of
breaking down its monoliths into a bunch
of micro services meaning these small I
guess loosely coupled very easily
deployable pieces of code so once we
actually broke down our the monoliths
into a bunch of micro services we
started to containerize them using
docker once we had a ton of containers
we realized that we should in fact use
something like kubernetes to manage and
schedule these containers but then also
get a lot of the awesome features that
kubernetes has available but Coubertin
these alone can be a little bit
complicated to use so we decided to
build an internal abstraction layer on
top of it
known as docc or the digital ocean
command center just very obvious naming
there but now that we had a bunch of
pods running in kubernetes pods being
like a group of containers we also
happen to have a bunch of services that
were still running as hypervisor daemons
we had a ton of hypervisors and a ton of
data centers we also had a lot of
virtual machines and we had our
kubernetes clusters themselves we
realized that there are a lot of moving
parts and we definitely needed some
introspection into these services which
led us to the three pillars of
observability so how has everyone heard
of the three pillars of observability
okay I'm just gonna quickly go through
that definition as well there's
distributed tracing so it's a way to
construct a directed acyclic graph of
it's a different directed acyclic graph
as you have these spans which are timed
operations and certain context created
and propagated through these timed
operations throughout your services
tracing also allows you to break down
and look into causality of certain
latency issues so it's very useful in
that sense we also have centralized
logging so all our logs from different
services in both kubernetes or may be
running on a hypervisor themselves do
you get sent to a centralized logging
cluster and then finally we also started
to get metrics using that Prometheus
solution which I mentioned essentially a
time series of data from instrumented
services so I mentioned that we use
Prometheus but really the truth is that
we used a lot of Promethea we actually
had a set up that sort of functionally
charted them and we use them to monitor
everything from both the hypervisors and
the virtual machines to the kubernetes
clusters themselves to different
services that were running both on the
hypervisors or in kubernetes the result
was we got these beautiful dashboards of
different services we got wonderful
distributed traces and could really
break down the
didn't see of our services or maybe
break down the latency of a call is it
traversed all the way from like the
front end to the lowest part of the
hypervisor and we could also look at our
logs I was great but around this time I
realized that I wanted a different sort
of challenge for the last two years
I'd largely worked on internal developer
tooling but I kind of wanted to work
closer to the cloud primitives meaning
like networking your storage or compute
and then I also wanted to work closer to
building the products for our actual
customers so in 2018
last year I ended up moving over to the
networking team one of the first thing
or specifically the software-defined
networking team and one of the first
things that I worked on at digitalocean
in the networking pillar was DHCP or our
implementation of a DHCP server and then
eventually moved on and currently I'm
working on the gateways team which is
kind of changing our networking
architecture so when I joined the
networking team there are a lot of terms
that especially coming from a background
that wasn't in computer science that I
had heard thrown around but I like
became very intimately familiar with for
example the OSI model learning about a
socket the different types of socket
socket programming all the ways in which
one could use a socket and then finally
I had a huge awakening and learned a lot
about different network protocols and
how to implement them as well but this
year I guess at the beginning of this
year after having all this networking
experience over the last year I also
realized that it might be fun to just
randomly build other networking
primitives obviously not something that
was necessarily production ready because
building a production ready load
balancer is a lot of work but more so
just something fun to kind of understand
the concepts and the fundamentals
underlying these services so that led me
to actually the subject of my talk today
which is how and when to use go to build
networking primitives so our plan was
we're first going to talk about why you
might want to use go and
perhaps when not to use go both
important things to consider we're then
going to G dive deep into the networking
stack and define some of those terms
that I had mentioned before and finally
we're going to end with actual examples
and some code snippets I promise they
won't be long of different Network
primitives so for example layer seven
versus layer four load balancer a port
scanner or a DHCP server so let's start
why might you want to use go to build
networking services there's a lot of
reasons there are those concurrency
primitives that I mentioned before we've
got our go routines our channels our
sink package go is also meant to be used
server-side and for a lot of our
networking services they are in fact
either powering the cloud running in
kubernetes running server-side or
actually running on the hypervisors
themselves as daemons go also has a lot
of third-party packages that makes it
that make it particularly easy to use
for building CLI tools furthermore one
of my colleagues pointed both of these
things out he finds that goes makes it
very easy to fuzz test services and
especially when you're dealing with
networking services that may get
customer traffic this is pretty
important and then finally he also found
that compared to some other languages it
was very easy to write restful or RPC
services and go so when might go not be
the answer so we clearly saw a lot of
reasons why go is awesome but if you're
doing some really high-performance
packet processing and this is something
that we've also very extensively
discussed in our team go might not be
the answer for you so maybe if you need
to receive a million packets per second
for example then in this case there are
languages that are better suited for
this and even if you happen to write
your networking service and go for
example if you wanted to have user space
i/o you would still need to compile a
program with C bindings so it might just
be easier to do this in another language
but why do we use go on we being
digitalocean well first of all we
already use go so much we actually have
a mono repo called Cthulhu and
our mono repo actually has a logo as
well which you can see right there we
have a lot of shared packages within
Cthulhu which make it very convenient
you write a service and go within the
mono repo for example we have a wrapper
around here if you see that
automatically instruments all our G RPC
services do you have metrics we also
have wrappers around the Prometheus
golang client we have wrappers around
tracing we also have an internal logging
library there's a lot of things that
especially for new developers when you
write a go service within Cthulhu it's
very easy to get it up and running and
have it instrumented with everything you
need for observability on top of that a
lot of our networking services as I
mentioned use G RPC we also use a lot of
CLI tools both for debugging or for
whatever reason so here's kind of an
example of some of the services that are
running on our hypervisor as you can see
we're making a lot of G RPC calls we
also have CLI tooling and then finally I
think this is maybe the most important
thing there's this whole a dog about
engineers solving for performance before
it's ever an issue well in this case we
extensively load tests most of our
services before they ever go into
production what we found especially this
this common task to do it's something
that we recently wrote for the most
recent project we found that already our
our service was good enough that was
written and go to even handle abusive
traffic and so we didn't really need
more performance in fact we would
actually be handling and throttling our
traffic before he had ever even hit our
service due to the fact that it would be
abusive if it ever got to that level so
that's that's why we use go at
digitalocean but let's now dive into the
networking stack so some of these terms
that I mentioned before OSI are open
systems Android connect model so the OSI
model is a framework for thinking about
how packets might traverse
communications network so if you have
studied computer science or you're
interested in networking you've probably
heard of this if like me you hadn't this
in
'we was a little bit new especially when
working more deeply with it so each
layer in the OSI model is considered to
be served by the layer below it and
serve the layer above it so working from
the top to the bottom we've got our
application layer our presentation or
session transport layer for network data
link and all the way down to layer 1
which is our physical layer finally
there's also the tcp/ip model which has
become popular and is quite frequently
used alongside the OSI model so in the
tcp/ip model we actually combined the
top 3 layers and the bottom two layers
to have just the application transport
network and physical layers something I
really want to hone in on and this is
actually going to be very important when
we start discussing those networking
primitives is the idea of data
encapsulation basically what happens as
you have your packets traversing through
the layers and then having headers added
or having header stripped away it's the
best way to look at this is by actually
looking at the payloads and different
units of data so if we're moving from I
guess your right to your left on the
right hand side we have a segment which
is the unit that we're dealing with at
the transport layer or layer 4 so in our
segment we've got our TCP segment
payload we've got our protocol in the
header our protocol port numbers and the
header but if we move down one more
layer to layer 3 or the IP layer we're
now dealing with an IP packet and so
that entire TCP segment is shoved into
the IP packet payload and our layer 3
header has the destination and source IP
address if we move down yet another
layer which is in the red we now have an
Ethernet frame and our entire IP packet
is basically within the ethernet frame
payload and our Ethernet frame header
has our destination and source MAC
address ok let's actually go back so now
that you know the types of data that
we're dealing with and the type sub
headers how do we actually read this
data in a program and that
turning to the idea of sockets more
generally they're defined as an internal
network that you can use or an internal
endpoint sorry that you can use to send
or receive data there's a lot of
different types of sockets and I think
the best way to kind of see what exists
is by thinking about the different types
of data so let's talk about a segment on
later for how do we read a segment well
there's two ways there's a TCP or
streaming socket which provides a
connection connection oriented very
sequenced flow of data that will arrive
in order
there's also UDP which also happens to
be a protocol which provides kind of a
connectionless flow of data so your
segments might actually arrive out of
order but if we wanted to drop down a
little bit further maybe we wanted we
really wanted those layer 3 headers or
maybe we really just wanted either net
frames there too we would need to use
something called raw sockets which are
sockets that don't have that protocol
specific higher layer formatting so the
the thing I definitely want to mention
and this is something that I even
struggled with because I found that
quite often people would use the term or
raw socket and packet socket fairly
interchangeably but in fact there is a
difference the socket syscall is very
similar for both however it does differ
and while a raw socket offers you access
to layer 3 stuff the packet socket is
what will allow you to access those link
layer or layer 2 headers and this is
going to be important later on just to
add a little more complexity to this
there are other ways that you can send
and receive link layer data there's BPF
interfaces but then the BPF filters from
your BPF interfaces also can be used
with raw sockets or you've prop Brahe
sockets or packet sockets or most
frequently you've probably seen them
used with TCP dump and before we exit
networking lands let's just talk really
quickly about protocols I'm just gonna
throw this chart up here and highlight a
few things which are going to make sense
when we go into our example so way at
the top
we have our layer seven or application
layer you'll see we have DHCP which is
the service I mentioned that I first
worked on when I moved to the networking
team there's of course HTTP HTTPS if we
move down a little bit further into the
transport layer or layer four you see
the TCP and UDP protocols and if we move
down further
other popular protocols that you've
probably heard of and layer two are
protocol okay so now that we've gone
through that it's probably a lot this is
pretty much my face like constantly when
building networking services or
debugging networking issues also my face
frequently when dealing with this but I
am gonna quote myself some might say
it's narcissistic but the best way to
learn is simply by doing and that's
actually why I ended up building a lot
of these services that I'm going to talk
about so let's get right down to it
let's start with a load balancer so
first thing I built and how this came
about was I think I just just talked to
some friends outside of work mention
that I joined the networking team one of
them mentioned why don't we build a load
balancer or just build random things I
thought it was a good idea and we
started performing every week to just
try to build the different networking
concepts so the first thing we built was
a layer seven load balancer so before we
get to it what is a load balancer this
is probably something everyone has
either encountered and advertently you
might have not even known it or perhaps
you've dealt with it directly or maybe
you've used an open source load balancer
like AJ proxy essentially it's a device
that distributes traffic across a number
of backends so as a client you might try
to connect to a certain website and the
load balancer will actually direct you
to one of multiple backends so in our
case we wanted to build a layer seven
load balancer and use HTTP protocol it's
super simple all we're doing is
accepting client-side connections
reading a request to passing that
request to one of the backends and then
returning our response back to the
client so a quick definition before I
move on HTTP protocol that is a protocol
that we will be using with our
load balancer it is request response
based it has a ton of different methods
it is stateless and under the hood it
can use TCP or UDP sockets but a lot of
that is extracted away in the library
that we're using which is the net HTTP
HTTP library and go so step one in our
load balancer is all we're doing is
we're listening and we're surveying on
port 8080 and then we also have a
handler function that will essentially
be getting that request and then writing
back a certain response within our
handler function you can see that in a
very sophisticated manner we're
selecting very randomly one of the
backends copying over that request and
sending it to the back-end again finally
we're just going to get that response
back from our back-end and essentially
copy it over and send it back to our
client so very simple little load
balancer here the thing though is maybe
we don't actually want a layer seven
load balancer on one hand it takes a lot
of system resources to process all the
way header all the headers all the way
up to layer seven and secondly we may
not even care about what protocols go
over our load balancer which kind of led
us to this layer for load balancer or as
we called it via TCP proxy so our
illiterate layer for load balancer a
little different right now instead of
using that net HTTP package we decided
to directly use a streaming socket on
top of that we decided to so sorry we
decided to use a streaming socket with
the TCD protocol and then we kind of
broke it down into two parts and this is
kind of a naive approach in a way but
for the sake of just us learning we
decided to do this and I'll talk a
little bit about what a real-life load
balancer might do later so we would
accept client-side connections and then
for every client-side connection that we
would get would open a back-end
connection and then use two goroutines
so here's that concurrency primitive and
go one we're using one go routine to
shuttle packets from the client to the
back-end and we're using
another go routine to shuttle packets
back from the back end to the client
it's a quick definition before we get to
it
TCP transmission control protocol is the
connection oriented protocol that we're
using with the streaming socket for a
TCP proxy so one of the thing the core
elements of this is the TCP handshake
that is used to establish a connection
so a client will essentially send a syn
the server will respond and then the
client once it gets that message will
acknowledge it so to build our TCP proxy
we use the net library we didn't
actually use the net HTTP sub package
but the net package itself to directly
open that streaming socket on top of
that we use this third-party library
which is actually based upon some
elements of the standard library but it
differs in a way and this this library
essentially allows us to concurrently
start a number of go routines
simultaneously and then maybe exit them
if one of them happens to exit so step
one is that we're going to open a TCP
socket and then we're going to bind it
locally to a certain port we're going to
wait from incoming connections from our
client and the client will come in with
some sort of with some remote address
and source port that the OS selects and
our listener will accept that connection
so for each of those connections we'll
then move all the way in the bottom to
the handle connection go routine and
within that as I mentioned this is like
the super naive part we're actually
opening a new back-end connection so now
we're going to open and connect a
back-end TCP socket to a remote address
and port once we do that this is where
we use those actor go routines that I
mentioned we have two go routines that
we're starting at the same time one is
essentially copying packets from our
client connection to our back-end and
one is copying packets back from our
back-end to our client and we are
starting these simultaneously and if one
of them happens to exit the other go
routine will be terminated as well
uh I mean yeah why not go ahead wait
which which oh so that you're
essentially adding a function and the
error function in the event that so
you're not starting the go routines
until the end but then you're
essentially adding the function that you
want to be run within the go routine as
well as the function that you want to be
run in case it exits yeah yeah and so
then so within those go routines
actually we're just essentially copying
over bytes of data from the client to
the backend or the backend to the client
so I mentioned that this was an
extremely naive approach and I'm gonna
now get into why so layer four load
balancers should be more efficient in
general it's pretty inefficient to
create a new connection every time you
have an incoming client connection we're
going to we'll be doing a TCP handshake
every single time in that case in
reality what a lot of load balancers do
is use something called Nats or network
address translation quite frequently
they will somehow munge incoming packets
and perhaps just forward those packets
straight to our back-end and one way
would be to do that for an incoming syn
packet to establish a TCP connection and
the connection will be directly
established with the backend the other
thing I want to mention is our load
balancing algorithm was super simple
here we literally were just randomly
selecting one of X number of backends in
reality however there's a lot of load
balancing algorithms out there there's
IP hashing there's the leased
connections method there's round-robin
load balancing by which traffic is just
equally distributed amongst the backends
and something else to consider is client
stickiness and one of the methods I
mentioned IP hashing could potentially
help with that so for example if your
back-end happened to be caching some
information about your clients it would
make sense for traffic from the same
client
to go to the same back-end so all of
these things important to consider when
actually making a real-life production
ready efficient load balancer so now
that we're still on layer 4 let's move
over to the port scanner so working on
this port scanner we're inspired by an
map well if you're not familiar with it
it's the Linux utility that allows you
to scan hosts and try to find open UDP
or TCP ports so here's kind of the
result of using an map on one particular
remote host we can see the ports that
are open we can also see there's a lot
of closed ports so actually before I
move on so in our case we wanted to
limit this just for the sake of our
example it's easy to kind of test an
open TCP port because we need to
establish a connection with it but for a
connectionless protocols such as UDP it
would be a little bit more involved
quite often you would actually need a
response from the from the server itself
to indicate that the port is in fact
open and you might sound like an ICMP
requests at it
so moving on in this case we actually
ended up using the sink package so
before we had used run groups which are
based on the sink package now we're
using the sink package itself so how do
we build a TCP port scanner this is
actually even simpler than our TCP proxy
because all we're doing is picking a
range of ports we're just trying to open
and connect to one of those remote
addresses and then we're printing our
results if we have an error and we can't
actually establish a connection we're
just going to assume that it's the port
is closed so step one same thing as
before actually very similar code the
only difference is now we're actually
having adding a timeout so we're just
trying to open and connect a TCP socket
to a remote address and port and if it's
closed we're printing that out if it's
open and we succeed
we're also printing that out and we're
making sure we close the connection the
other thing is of course we could do
this all sequentially but it would make
more sense to do this concurrently so we
are using wait groups a little bit
different from the run groups from
before whereas those run groups and
start after
routines at the same time the weight
groups will actually cause the main
thread to block while our sub go
routines are executing and something
else that's kind of cool which is a
pattern that I've come to use a lot is
using a buffered channel which you can
kind of see at the top we're making a
channel with an empty struck that
happens to have a size of ten so it uses
this construct a lot to kind of limit
the number of concurrent go routines
that I can have in a service so in this
case we start our go routine we're
adding something to the channel so it
fills up when we're done with the go
routine we're reading from the channel
so it empties out so it's like a super
useful construct so in real life however
nmap will actually do both UDP and TCP
scanning it'll do host discovery it'll
do OS detection and as you can imagine
all of this is very useful for auditing
like security and a network security the
firewall security of a remote host so
we've gone all the way from layer seven
to layer four but maybe we wanted to go
a little bit lower and that actually
brings me to the DHCP server but before
we go on all of you are probably like or
maybe you aren't but you should be
skeptical because DHCP is technically a
layer seven protocol or application
layer protocol if you recall the OSI
chart I had before it was all the way at
the top so why are we doing this at this
like layer two but before we get there
quick definition DHCP protocol it's
probably used by a lot of your home
routers to allocate IP addresses to
networking interfaces it's a protocol
that kind of makes use of it client and
a server we actually ended up
implementing the DHCP server as a
hypervisor daemon at digitalocean
largely because we were releasing a new
product that allowed customers to bring
their own image and in order for their
droplets or virtual machines to actually
get network connectivity we needed to
dynamically allocate those IP addresses
so how G HTTP protocol typically works
is let's say on your VM your DHCP client
comes up sends out a discover message
frequently multicast it then the DHCP
server will send back an offer often
with an IP address in the body then the
DHCP client will get
it'll send a DHCP request and the DHCP
server will acknowledge it and then
finally frequently the DHCP client will
also do some sort of art broadcast to
verify that it is a valid IP address so
the reason that we actually wanted to
drop all the way down to layer two is we
wanted to do some kind of validation so
I mentioned before that we have that
DHCP request that the client will be
sending to the server it will ultimately
be having our source MAC address from
our DHCP client as well as the IP
address that we're getting what we
wanted to do was confirm that the source
MAC address that's in the body of the
DHCP request happens to be the same as
that source MAC address that is in the
header of our Ethernet frame this would
allow us to kind of detect if a certain
DHCP clients were spoofing behavior and
detect bad actors so to build a decency
HTTP server however now we're finally
dropping down and we're using those raw
sockets or specifically packet sockets
so we used a library to open and find a
raw socket to an interface then we
essentially read from that interface we
and marshaled that DHCP message and then
we tried appending on the type of DHCP
message we had we had different handlers
we finally were to validate the DHCP
message if it happened to be of the
request type finally we would craft a
response and send that response back to
our sender so one of the packages that
we used for this is something that my
colleague actually previously wrote Matt
layer called the raw package if we kind
of dive into the raw package we can see
that on Linux systems he's actually
using packet sockets essentially opening
a socket binding it to the interface and
then reading from the socket on FreeBSD
however he's using the beep BPF
interfaces which I had mentioned earlier
something you'll also notice in both of
these code examples is that we're using
a bunch of other packages from the
standard library we're using OS we're
using syscall and then we're also using
this other package called Unix in order
to open our sockets
so I also want to highlight that quite
frequently and this is what Matt ended
up doing because the NGO standard
library and especially than that package
didn't really have exactly what he
needed for packet sockets he created his
own library using syscall and OS and the
UNIX package which happens to also use
this call and OS under the hood so in
order to do this all we're doing is
opening and binding a raw socket to the
interface something else I want to point
out is we're creating this socket and
binding it to the interface we are
specifying the ethertype and header so
here we're saying ethertype ipv4 meaning
that we're expecting the ipv4 IP v4
protocol type data to come over this raw
socket and so technically this code
snippet was actually from RG h CP v4
server so we were expecting ipv4
messages second Lane once we have that
socket open we would read incoming data
into a buffer on a package that pass it
into a channel have one of our workers
in our channels handling that request
and here you can kind of see we're using
that that same idea of a buffered
Channel and a limited number of workers
to serve our requests same idea that we
were using before when we created the
port scanner so finally this is where
we're doing that validation we're
actually reading our DHCP packet that's
been pushed into another type of struct
but we're also comparing that to what we
have in our packet or in our frame
header that source MAC address and if in
fact they're not equal we're just
sending an invalid message back to our
client otherwise if it's not invalid
we'll just send back a happy response so
the the main I mean obviously the the
full production ready DHCP server was
way more code than this but for the sake
of this example I just wanted to point
out two main things one we're using raw
sockets and two we decided to use raw
sockets and jump down to the link layer
because we wanted to do source Mac
validation so that leads me to my
conclusion so if there's anything
learned from all of this it's that go
can be good for building networking
primitives is it always the language you
want to use not necessarily but it can
be good and then when we're discussing
layers for layer seven we have the net
HTTP package within the standard library
if we're jumping down further we have
the net package and if we're jumping
down even further we have the raw
package but we can also use the OS
package or the syscall package or use
other third-party packages to give us
access to that link layer data that we
need and even outside like outside of
networking there's a lot of cool
features and go when it comes to
concurrency primitives with the sync
package error groups weight groups like
all of these ideas of actor go routines
being able to be started or terminated
as well as goroutines and channels so
thank you and before I end I just wanted
to thank some of my colleagues that
layer who actually ended up writing the
raw package that we used within DHCP my
other colleague Nick and then julius who
happened to pear program with me on a
lot of different networking primitives
so thanks if you have any questions
yeah that's a good point
we did have to add we did have to have
root permissions or specific like user
groups in order to do this but they were
running as hypervisor level daemons so
we had that permission we preferred it
for pretty much most of our networking
services that are running on the
hypervisor we do have root permission
and the right bra capabilities added to
the groups yep
yeah so I would say that I think it had
a lot to do with the growth of the
company and the products that were being
created and then being able to have the
right velocity to kind of diverge into
separate pillars and separate teams so
we've started I think moving over to
using kubernetes and the micro services
when I joined the company and before I
think and this is true for a lot of
companies when they create their first
product or their MVP they might use
something like Ruby or rails or
what-have-you to create it just because
it's really fast to work in but then at
a certain point it becomes too big and
then there's also a ton of latency
that's introduced so I think it was the
combination of latency the combination
of the size of the teams needing to work
independently and then also the
combination of like releasing a lot of
products and those products being able
to be released separately or worked on
by people with completely different
skills
this actually kind of predates my time a
little bit I know before we even use go
and there's still some parts that are
written in Perl I think the original
founders of our company at this point
the company's like seven or eight years
old I think the original founders had
written a lot of the back end in Perl so
that was the I guess original language
of digital ocean and then rails and then
I think we ended up moving to go just
because it was it was a very easy
language for people to adopt especially
people with an on go background or non
like systems background and I think
that's part of the reason why it started
to be adopted
I guess maybe like in 2014 or so and
then I guess the one thing that people
always ask about is why would ended up
with a mono repo in fact I'm really
surprised that I haven't had any mono
repo questions yet I think I don't know
the original reasonings and I think
there's still some debates about it so I
think after a few years after starting
to use go they decided to move all the
code into the mono repo just because
they created all these shared libraries
and then when they had a small team it
was far easier to employ teams to use
the shared libraries so that every
service would have observability rather
than relying on every team to handle
vendor and handle setting up logging
correctly and whatnot
yeah I think the the only the main pain
point however which has just been a pain
point would go in general is ven during
and ven during dependencies and
especially if different teams want
different versions of things but aside
from that the benefits are great oh so
we definitely do use context and
cancellation I think just with that
particular case where I was using run
groups we didn't necessarily need
context propagation and then I wanted to
have those two go routines start at the
exact same time but we do but we do use
error groups a lot and we do definitely
use a lot of context cancellation and
cancellation especially when we're
dealing with like our PC services
oh yeah this was like so it should be
clear this is definitely not something
to be used at scale I think in terms of
our handling when it comes to TCP load
balancing at scale honestly I'm not a
hundred percent sure how things like a
shape proxy handle it perhaps that's a
good question yeah I mean I think
technically especially given that you're
running within these go routines I think
also using for example like a retry
block would be something that's entirely
possible and then I know that we also
use kind of like our channels before
we've also just immediately logged this
and then we have we could potentially
although this isn't the best strategy
for a production load balancer I was
thinking more so just for some of our
like hypervisor level services we just
immediately have them crash and systemd
handles restarting them just because
it's easier to do that rather than
trying retry but when it comes to a load
balancer that would be a terrible
strategy so don't do that so yeah so
like I mentioned I think ven during that
had been a pain point in the past and I
think that we do have a we sort of have
a go team of the company attempting to
address it so quite frankly I think for
example I think there's a kubernetes
like API library and I think two
different teams are using two different
versions of it and two vendor both of
them into the mono repo created some
issues when we because we I think at
this point we've been using go so long
that we've gone through like all the
vendor Aang
I guess attempts in the community so I
think that was definitely one issue and
that also happened when we use terraform
like different teams were using
different versions of it so I think that
was definitely one of the issues
yeah we actually just I think maybe
earlier this year did start looking into
go modules as to whether it's helped
address some of the pain points I think
it might be a little too early to say
definitively but hopefully oh and I
guess one of the other things
speaking of Monterey posts that I
realized is at some point you can have a
mono repo that's extremely large and
that github enterprise has trouble
supporting awesome I guess that's pretty
much it thank you everyone